um let's see what's going on here in a
live chat we got a super from uh Greg
Paulie's question about watch games
thinking about buying a Rolex can you
hit three birds the one stone investment
network with other success successful
men get girls wet or do girls have no
clue about watches I'll tell you
something
um girls really don't have any clue
about watches I um
I had this friend of mine that bought a
fake uh breitlin but I think they're
pronounced Breitling or Breitling or
something like that
um he said it was like a 40 50 000 watch
you know if you were to buy it at that
time this is a while ago this is
probably
um I don't know 15 years ago or so
um put it on you know we went on our
trip to uh I don't know we went Vegas
Ibiza you know something like that and
uh you know women were looking at it and
going hey is that a Breitling that's a
nice watch sort of thing and they had no
clue it was fake and if you took it off
and you picked it up it's heavy I don't
know if they put lead weights in or
whatever it is but he paid a couple
hundred bucks for this like fake replica
um so do you know can women tell the
difference no uh but the high-end watch
Market has done very well
um I've seen people make big returns off
of
um nice watches not my thing I I don't
even wear a watch like I have you know
my aura ring and a couple other Viking
rings that I you know picked up but
that's but that's really about it
um yeah I don't I don't really like
watches personally I've got a couple of
watches I got some tag hoyers um
the idea of investing in watches and
wearing your restaurant so one of the
cool things that you could do I mean if
you have a Rolex that's worth I don't
know a million bucks or something like
that you could put it on your wrist hop
on a plane fly to another country you
can take that off your wrist and you can
sell it locally right you could do the
same thing with Bitcoin on something
that's very small and not as easy to
identify and steal right I mean if
you're walking around with a million
dollar Rolex
um and there's people that
you know will hold you up for stuff like
that which you're going to run into in
certain places of the world and you know
cities
um you could lose that money very very
quickly so
um yeah I mean if you know what you're
doing doing it I I don't do it it's not
my thing
um
what's his name PJ
Piedmont he's got
um something called The Watch Trading
Academy if I'm not mistaken I had him on
a plane to win podcasts a while back
um you know we were talking about
you know his life in his in his business
with the cars and one of the things that
he's big on is his watches so if you
want more info I'd say go and you know
go and check that out so shout out to
him hey guys I really hope that you
enjoyed that short clip if you did
consider supporting the creation of
content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unpluggedalpha.com forward
slash shop when you click through you'll
be able to land over here and the entire
lineup is broken down by category that
it performs best in estrogen metabolism
fat burning your foundational Essentials
for health immune Health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code Alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the Subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching I
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out